the fifth day of the full-scale war of  russia against the people of ukraine we  stand strong we live through that much  over these days what other people  wouldn't experience in decades  some diplomacy is taking place between  russia and ukraine a delegation met on  the belarus border it's unknown what was  talked about but it came as the eu  parliament held a special session about  the russian invasion of ukraine this  half a billion of users will be devoted  to provide defensive arms but  high caliber arms  anti-tanks  all kind of agreements in order to repel  the aggression  tanks roll into kharkiv  missiles are seen on the roads as  fighter jets fly overhead  [Music]  residents film the damage east of  kharkiv near the russian border  in eastern ukraine fuel tanks burn  and the scene is repeated in northern  ukraine and will be over the coming days  as both sides fight on imran khan  al-jazeera  and we take you